panic not play at this nursery in
eastern ukraine
it was shelled in one of a number of
attacks on a tense front line
this mess on one side blamed on
russia-backed separatists who hold
territory on the other
hand
it unfolded on the same day ukraine's
president visited troops in the region
in a war of words as well as weapons the
separatists accused his forces of being
the ones using violence
untrue says the government but western
allies worry the unrest could be an
attempt by russia to create a false
attack or provocation that's blamed on
ukraine and used as an excuse to invade
britain's prime minister sounding if not
quite looking concerned
i wish i could give everybody better
news about this but i have to tell you
that the picture is
continuing to be very grim i do think
it's it's there is still time
for the the putin regime to step back
there's still time to avoid a
catastrophe a catastrophe
for russia a catastrophe for ukraine and
for the world a map unusually shared by
the uk's ministry of defense shows what
had dubbed president vladimir putin's
possible axis of invasion
the arrows track how troops could push
to kiev and the city of danipra before
spreading out
yet russia insists a massive buildup of
troops is starting to withdraw from
around ukraine after finishing exercises
even though western officials say it's
building up and moving closer
how would you feel if this were to
happen like a war in europe on your
watch as foreign secretary how would you
feel it would be absolutely terrible for
european security
for russia
and for ukraine and i fear that it
wouldn't stop at ukraine this is why we
have to be resolute in the face of
russian aggression
the fate of these russian forces in
belarus is seen as a key indicator
their exercises should finish at the
weekend but if their presence doesn't
start to reduce too
then western allies fear the worst debra
haynes sky news kiev